[Music]  they gave me a skull  not a real one no you're human yeah  why would they give you a fake human  skull  so that you can  it's a very famous skill  is it yeah but it's a fake one i don't  understand they've given you a fake  famous human skull yeah so they dug a  guy why are you being suspicious a guy  in africa dug up this skull and it  proves something ah  i can't remember what it proves this is  what they would tell us yeah possibly  possibly possible  that we thought humans  were around yes or when their brains  were a certain size or whatever  anyway i'll get them on they'll discuss  all this yeah yeah we'll dig into it  well that's where the old  [Music]  all through daytime night you're shining  bright i'm your boy's the baby you're my  [Music]